bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette édition
spéciale que nous consacrons à
l'élection présidentielle nous recevons
ce soir nicolas sarkozy bonsoir bonsoir
mais si on veut inviter mais merci
d'être là en demain c'est ségolène royal
qui fera cette place interrogé par jean
michel vié et catherine matausch nicolas
sarkozy au lendemain du débat qui vous a
opposé à ségolène royal j'ai envie de
savoir quelles sont les leçons et que
vous avez tiré de ce débat je suis pas
su pas le meilleur observateur extérieur
puisque j'étais un acteur mais d'abord
je voudrais dire une première chose
c'est que d'après ce qu'on a dit il y
avait plus de 20 millions de
téléspectateurs c'est fantastique la
démocratie française est de retour les
gens sont de nouveaux passionnés par les
débats ensuite avec madame royal nous
avons essayé d'avoir un débat digne
point le plus intéressant possible j pas
qu'on est arrivé mais le plus
intéressant possible qu'il y ait un
gagnant beaucoup tes chute plus mal
placé pour le dire je vois bien les
sondages qui sortait ce qu'ils disent
mais moi je me garderai de lui dire ça
serait discourtois pour la personne avec
qui j'ai débattu et puis je pense que
ces événements sont moins décisif qu'on
imagine plus médiatique est moins
décisif et que par ailleurs j'imagine
que dans les 20 millions de
téléspectateurs il y en a beaucoup qui
ont pensé que la moyenne habité meilleur
que moi quelques uns qui ont dû penser
que c'est l inverse et beaucoup d'autres
et ça qui est important qu'ils sont dit
au fond il n'y a peut-être pas de
vainqueurs ou des vaincus on s'est fait
une idée plus précise de notre choix est
ce qu avait été surpris par la colère
des collègues royal pas la colère j'ai
tout de suite vu sur le plateau que
cette colère était un peu fade
ban
on n'était pas face à faire selon vous
je me permets pas de dire ça mais enfin
d'abord il s'est trompé sur les chiffres
les associations d'enfants handicapés
l'ont dit et l'a osé dire que nous
avions diminué le nombre de places pour
les enfants handicapés ils ont été
multiplié par deux je pense que c'est
pas bien de mentir
elle s'est également trompé sur les
chiffres en matière nucléaire de façon
assez lourde
bon je crois qu'elle cherchait être très
pugnace et que parfois elle a été trop
agressif alors c'est les dernières
heures les derniers jours de campagne
cet après midi dans le monde françois
bayrou affirme qu'il ne votera pas pour
vous sans dire d'ailleurs ce qu'il fera
dimanche pour vous c'est un choix
personnel c'est une rupture n'auront pas
vrai d'abord moi je respecte le choix de
françois bayrou je sais pas pourquoi il
s'est mis dans cette situation-là nos
programmes sont très proches
nous avons été amis pendant des années
je crois que il se prépositionner jarre
pour la présidentielle de 2012 j'ai
envie de lui dire un resto calme qui a
déjà celle de 2007 à faire et on n'est
pas dans 2012 mais surtout depuis tous
ces élus m'ont rejoint tous les
parlementaires et les dernières études
montrent qu'une majorité d'électeurs de
l'udf aujourd'hui me rejoignent et c'est
très près normal puisque mon programme
est compatible avec le sien alors que le
programme de ben hammou ryan ne l'est
pas justement voudrais comprendre qu'est
ce que vont devenir
au delà du 6 mai c'est député udf qui
vous ont rejoint est-ce qu'il intègre eu
un courant udf
pour moi les choses sont claires l'udf a
toute sa place dans la nouvelle majorité
présidentielle si j'ai la majorité je
souhaite une majorité diverses
je souhaite respecter l'indépendance et
l'identité des centristes
et c'est à eux de décider commune eux
comment ils s'organisent lui de toute
manière françois bayrou devient porte
devoir bien choisir une alliance et si
rénover la vie politique cdja je vote
blanc bah il fait comme jean marie le
pen
juste une question très courte le
conseil constitutionnel réclament depuis
longtemps un redécoupage des
circonscriptions ce sera sans doute
après les législatives
ou est ce que c'est une wii c'est
n'obligera pas comment pour rené grand
rodez veut dire que à cette occasion on
peut introduire comme vous l'avez dit
une petite dose de proportionnelle et à
quel niveau vous mettez la petite dose
de oui ok c'est un sujet très complexe
je vais très clair dessus je ne suis pas
favorable à la proportionnelle comme
système général parce que j'ai peur je
crains le retour aux origines des
parties 1 et on a vu les agitations de
l'entre-deux-tours royal bayrou et c'est
bon en revanche c'est un problème qui
est préoccupant c'est qu'il ya des
grands courants d'opinion qui ne sont
pas représentés je pense aux verts a pas
je pense à l'extrême droite à l'extrême
gauche et donc est ce qu'on peut
introduire une petite dose de
proportionnelle
pourquoi pas est-ce que ça doit être au
sénat il ya déjà la proportionnelle à
l'assemblée nationale et en tout état de
cause je fixerai une règle c'est celle
qui consiste à dire que ça doit se faire
à nombre de parlementaires constant
c'est à dire que si on crée de la
proportionnelle à l'assemblée d'une
petite dose
il faudra supprimer des députés au
scrutin majoritaire et si on le fait
aussi avancer quoi une centaine par
exemple pas plus en aucun cas vous
parliez tout à l'heure de l'appel à
l'abstention de jean marie le pen pour
vous cet appel à l'abstention c'est
plutôt une bonne ou mauvaise nouvelle
écoutez vous savez j'ai tout perdu je me
fais s'il avait dit voter pour moi on
m'aurait un câble et que toutes les
injures habituel s'arrêter le fier
service à vous rendre non jeu du passeur
homme ou fond vous savez au document
j'attache assez peu d'importance aux
consignes données par jean marie le pen
et par françois bayrou parce que moi dès
le début de la campagne j'ai essayé de
me mettre dans un dans un discours
différent
j'ai voulu parler aux français sans
intermédiaire ce qu'est la logique de
l'action puisque si vous vouliez avant
le premier tour reconquérir une partie
de l'électorat de jean-marie le pen
manifestement on va prendre plutôt
l'électorat populaire mais je marie le
méné qui revient avec apparemment en
particulier les résultats est revenu
vers vous est ce que là pour le deuxième
tour vous allez de nouveau vous adresser
mais moi je ne veux pas changer
enfin si je trouve d'ailleurs
invraisemblable qu'on puisse dire on va
changer de programme entre le premier et
deuxième tours il ya quinze jours il ya
11 millions et demi de français qui ont
voté pour moi au premier tour je vais
pas les trahir
alors je dois hilare jir la majorité
c'est la logique du deuxième tour aux
tribus 1 mais je dois rester chemin
discours quel est mon discours je dis
aux français je vous parle à vous je
prends pas la pensée unique
je pense pas aux élites je crois pas au
chanteur
pardon parlement au delà des
journalistes ce qui m'intéresse c'est de
convaincre les français qu'ils aient des
solutions aux problèmes qui sont les
leurs c'est ça que j'ai essayé de faire
est bon la plus belle satisfaction c'est
les 85 % de participation au premier
tour
la démocratie française est de retour ça
prouve que la campagne était
intéressante souvenez vous je me vient
vite et on avait débattu de cette
histoire d'identité d'immigration les
françaises ont tranché ils ont été
passionnés par ce débat la question du
travail ça les a passionnés alors à
propos de la question du travail
justement c'est l'un des thèmes centraux
de la campagne et de votre campagne vous
promettez d'ici cinq ans le plein emploi
vous appuyez beaucoup sur les exemples
de l'irlande de la grande-bretagne
encore de l'espagne qui ont
effectivement des taux de chômage très
bas du danemark de la suède il ya quand
même de la série oui mais juste sur la
question pour ces fonds ce qui concerne
ce que vont se sont décarcassés pas
renier mettons déjà l'irlande la
grande-bretagne et l'espagne d'un côté
ce coin des pays qu in qui ont
effectivement des taux de chômage très
bas mais avec énormément d'emplois
précaires avec beaucoup de travailleurs
pauvres
d'accord mais alors ex première dame
était le plat n'est pas regarder quel
type d'armé à quelle qualité de travail
me regarde et l'autriche
regardez le danemark regarder la suède
forte précarité alors il n'y a pas de
précarité mis un taux d'imposition
beaucoup plus lourd à une assiette
d'impôt sur le revenu beaucoup plus
large non plus de dan radio il vient de
réduire les impôts de 3 points suède et
supprimer l'impôt sur la fortune
oui mais ils sont quand même un bon prix
bien sûr mais aurait pu marquer la
première des priorités c'est le chômage
je dis aux français qui nous écoutent il
y a dix pays en europe en quête d'emploi
on fixe le plein-emploi grosso modo
entre 4 et 5% de chômeurs à l'autriche
et à 4,3 l'irlande et à quatre langues
le royaume uni et à 4,2 bas bon pourquoi
les autres le font pas nous alors on dit
hier la précarité je dis pas que ça
résout tous les problèmes mais c'est
quand même mieux d'avoir le plein emploi
est d'avoir des chômeurs mieux que ça au
royaume uni le taux de chômage ces trois
mois
un chômeur restent au chômage trois mois
quant à chômeurs est au chômage il est
reçu par le service public de l'emploi
au bout de 15 jours nous au bout de
quatre mois
y'a par la commune et irrigation
d'accepter c'est ce qu'on veut bien aux
médiations d'accepter des propositions
qui en grande bretagne ne sont ne
correspondent pas forcément à sa
formation et à ses souhaits en grande
bretagne c'est encore plus sévère que
nous mais enfin franchement ce que la
gauche anglaise a fait peut-être que la
droite française peut l'envisager
juste un mot sur votre conception de la
démocratie sociale je vais prendre deux
exemples qui ressort d'ailleurs en
partie du débat d'hier soir
ségolène royal dit à propos des 35
heures de sa nouvelle loi sur les 35
heures confie ça aux partenaires sociaux
s'ils se mettent pas d'accord il y aura
pas deux jours c'est ce que vous avez
entendu
bon vous vous dites à propos par exemple
du service minimum dans les transports
je confie ça aux partenaires sociaux
s'ils ne se mettent pas d'accord il y
aura une loi est ce que là il n'y a pas
deux sa préhension du dialogue social du
rôle des syndicats dans cette affaire
bon bah écoutez si on est candidat à la
présidentielle et on sait pas pourquoi
ça devient compliqué j'ai promis aux
français un service minimum en cas de
grève
ça fait 20 ans qu'on en parle 20 ans
qu'on ne fait pas toutes les études
d'opinion montrent que 80 % des français
sont d'accord sur un seul type d'accord
c'est monsieur thibault je le respecte
mais dans ce cas là il a qu à être
candidat à l'élection présidentielle
mon projet c'est pas l'immobilisme c'est
par le corporatisme c'est pas regarder
passer les trains pour le coup rien
faire je n'accepte pas cette idée que
tant de français qui habitent en
banlieue les jours de grève soient pris
en otages d'un conflit qui ne les
regarde pas donc on discutera que les
organisations syndicales des modalités
du calendrier des compensations mais la
démocratie politique c'est les électeurs
qui choisissent un candidat
j'ai été très clair sur mon projet si je
suis élu je m'étrangle est ce que vous
pensez que le patron de la sncf et la
patronne de la ratp par exemple sont
tout à fait d'accord sur ce principe
bah écoutez si la patronne de la ratp
n'est pas d'accord avec le représentant
de l'actionnaire c'est l'actionnaire qui
décide c'est quand même un comble comme
on dit qu aux non suspensif vulgairement
fin c'est comme ça voilà ici les
français votent pour quelqu'un qui a
promis quelque chose et que c'est
quelque chose rentrer dans les faits
paris tout à fait normal que la
démocratie politique et son rythme et
que les engagements qui ont été pris
avant l'élection soient tenus après la
sarkozie dans ledit baggy hier on a eu
l'impression peut-être parce que ni
ségolène royal ni vous n'avez encore
exercé des fonctions qui vous entraîne
sur le terrain de la politique étrangère
de la diplomatie etc
on a eu plus l'impression vous parliez
de problèmes qui concernent les français
au premier chef on est allé jusqu'à
remboursement des prothèses dentaires
etc
mais finalement la partie du débat
consacré aux questions internationales
étaient beaucoup moins importante
quel type de président serez-vous pour
ces questions là et est ce que la la la
diplomatie la défend sa politique
étrangère pour vous reste des domaines
réservés du président dont la notion de
domaine réservé au sens où il fait ce
qu'il veut le président c'est une notion
que je n'accepte pas c'est justement
parce que c'est important la défense est
important la politique étrangère qu'on
doit le débattre dans un cadre
démocratique
moi je suis le seul candidat qui est
quand même fait une conférence de presse
de 2h30 exclusivement consacrée aux
questions de la presse sur la politique
étrangère
alors c'est vrai qu'on en a peu parlé
moi je le regrette parce qu'il ya de
grands dossiers
je voudrais dire deux choses d'abord que
la stabilité c'est pas un objectif en
matière de politique étrangère au nom de
la stabilité en accepter galetas et on
était bien content 80 millions
d'européens soit sous le joug du
communisme
deuxièmement je ne crois pas la
realpolitik celle qui consisterait à
échanger ses principes ses valeurs
contre des contrats dans ce cas là on
gagne pas les contrats et on perd ses
principes
alors je vous comprennez et relations
avec des pays qui n'ont je je ne
changerai pas et démocratique pour
porter on peut être on peut être ami
avec la russie considérait que monsieur
poutine fait des choses très bien
il lui poser des questions sur
l'évolution la démocratie en russie ou
sur ce qui se passe en tchétchénie et
quand même il ya 900 mille tchétchène y
en a 250 me ont été tuées et 250 piquant
de quitter leur pays la france la patrie
des droits de l'homme ne peut pas rester
silencieuse bon j'ai un bibelot des
questions c'est jusqu'à quel point
c'était quand même engagé une action
pratique
num rendez compte depuis huit ans et
trois mois
ces pauvres femmes et le médecin
palestinien dur pour le même prix deux
condamnations à mort une collation
perpétuité on peut pas on peut pas
accepter ça ingrid betancourt faut aller
la chercher
il faut faire pression sur le président
est arrivé par l'intermédiaire des états
unis bon ces femmes lapidées parce que
soupçonnée d'adultère
qu est ce que c est un cauchemar vous
mettez en action comme en a beau écouter
moi je pense que le discours la parole
ça compte et que la voix de la france
elle est entendue
pour ça il faut qu'elle soit audible
mais on peut le dire en s'asseyant à la
même table
on peut quand même poser des questions
on peut dire voilà il ya des choses qui
nous déplaisent un des chantiers
prioritaires kora le futur président de
la république c'est l'europe
après le nom du ou des français au
référendum juste de question qu est ce
qui vous permet aujourd'hui penser que
nos partenaires européens accepteront
votre mini traité
et puis deuxième question comment ferez
vous acceptez aux français que
finalement si ce ministre était voit le
jour il leur passerait souvenait et qui
ne serait pas contre dallas attendait
d'abord parce que j'ai parlé de cette
question avec angela merkel avec josé
luis zapatero avec tony blair et trois
m'ont donné leur accord et même avec eux
manuel barroso voilà j'ai pris des
contacts avant va je veux dire on doit
se préparer à la fonction présidentielle
je dis pas que je serai élu mais j'ai dû
me préparer à ça deuxièmement la
constitution de richard destin malgré le
travail remarquable de mérite car des
salles verra pas le jour parce que les
français l'ont dit non est obsolète
après je dis pas qu'elle est obsolète ça
serait design ils ont dit non à ceux qui
disent faut faire un nouveau jardin mal
moi elle dit faut faire un nouveau
référendum mais sur quoi mon dieu une
nouvelle constitution
6il refaire leurs textes elle propose
des modifications alors à l'écouter on
va avoir le temps parce que l'or pour
mettre 27 pays d'accord sur une nouvelle
constitution de bulles mars on entendra
dans cinq ans et pour le prochain
quinquennat quand elle il faut faire un
nouveau référendum
c'est une plaisanterie si ce n'était si
grave bon je fais un nouveau référendum
sur l'actuelle constitution
je peux vous le dire ça sera non et
faire un nouveau référendum sur une
nouvelle constitution
il faut d'abord l'accord des 26 autres
pays vous imaginez donc je le dis aux
français la précision ne leur a pas
alors le mini-traité qu'est ce que c'est
ce n'est d'ailleurs j'ai passé par lyon
c'est moi qui prends pas
mauvaise exposition non non vous avez
raison c'est m la mienne mais j'ai
préféré me rues de leur ville
hélas hélas puisque j'ai retenu une
autre qui a traité simplifié ça consiste
à pas faire une constitution mais à
doter l'europe d'institutions nouvelles
notamment un président de l'union
européenne sur ces points tout le monde
est d'accord les partisans du non comme
les partisans du oui
nicolas sarkozy comme il nous reste peu
de temps j'aimerais avoir un petit peu
votre sentiment sur la façon dont cette
campagne s'est déroulé qu'est ce qu'elle
vous a appris sur vous et sur la france
voit sur la france d'abord qu'il y avait
un appétit de sens une volonté de
réflexion sur les valeurs
une quête d'identité stati intéressant
on n'a jamais vu une campagne qui ne
portait pas sur des mesures précises
mais elle portait sur un débat de valeur
regardez 97 ça s'est fait sur les 35
heures 2002 ça s'est fait sur la
sécurité
je crois qu'on pourra dire avec le recul
que 2007 ça s'est fait sur une quête de
sens et de ce point de vue est
intéressant qu'est-ce que ça m'a appris
sur moi-même je suis pas sûr que la
campagne présidentielle ça soye une
forme de substituer à un ami
psychologique mais je pense que je vais
pas vous dire quelque chose que j'ai été
dans tous ces deux longues années ces
longs mois
j'ai tout donné je n'ai pas été avare de
mes sentiments et je pense qu'une
campagne c'est une forme d'ascèse si on
veut comprendre un peuple partagé ses
douleurs et ses espérances
il faut se mettre en situation soit même
de les ressentir de les comprendre
parfois de souffrir est-ce que vous avez
le sentiment d'avoir commis une erreur
d'avoir tenu des propos qui peut-être
heureux enfin bombay ça je vous dise je
dirais plus dimanche à 21
vous parlez d'ascèse vous avez parlé
aussi de si vous étiez lui de prendre
quelques jours de réflexion de retraite
on a l'impression que le spirituel et le
religieux prennent de plus en plus de
place à la fin de la campagne dans vos
discours
c'est une question importante 7 du sens
de la vie c'est pas le religieux le pied
plutôt spirituel oui vous avez par
exemple parler de jean paul ii et qui
était une référence pour nous eh oui
mais je pense qu'on peut être dans le
doute
on peut être dans l'espérance et à
tracer admiratif devant la la force de
la foi d'un homme comme jean paul ii qui
a beaucoup compté dans le monde
oui c'est un homme qui va enfin kim kim
qui m'a touché quand il a dit n'ayez pas
peur aux jeunes
je trouvais que c'est un très très beau
message y avait chez lui un mélange de
fermeté et d'ouverture aux autres
bon je trouve que c'est très humain
c'est très intéressant
vous pensez parfois à la l'éventualité
de la défaite
parfois régulièrement bien sûr j'y pense
plus je joue encore moins parce que je
finalement deux manches consacre à ses
poteaux cet exercice de se raser mais il
faut être humble devant le résultat je
vous savez avant le premier tour j'étais
pas sûr d'être sélectionné pour le
second je me suis battu jusqu'à la
dernière minute les pôles de nature vous
n'était pas élu à dimanche
après quoi ah ben je pourrais prendre
des vacances plus tranquille qu'ils
avaient la ressource de remonter à
cheval aura tout cas la ressource de
partir en vacances de bien réfléchir à
ce qui a marché ce qui n'a pas marché et
d'en tirer les conclusions
mais là il faut pas se décider
maintenant regarder ce qu'il fait lionel
jospin en 2002 il avait décidé trop tôt
et trop vite
on dit souvent sous la 5e république
l'élection présidentielle c'est la
rencontre d'un peuple et d'un homme est
donc quelque part le futur président
quel qu'il soit incarne quelque chose et
il ya eu plusieurs modèles de présidence
de la république depuis le général de
gaulle vous comment vous voyez cette
incarnation si j'ose employer ce terme
là le président c'est l'homme de la
nation c'est pas l'homme d'un parti ce
pas l'homme d'un clan spa même d'une
secte le président doit elle avait pas
président arbitres et présidents plus de
regarder je serai un président qui
s'engageraient sur des résultats
j'ai la culture de résultat en moins
mais le président c'est quelqu'un qui
doit être capable d'aimer les français
pour les rassembler on ne peut
rassembler que des gens qu'on aime les
aimer tous les pans de tous sans
considération est allé moi je veux lui
proche des français que ne l'ont été en
2008 cette façon là
la proximité c'est pas simplement une
attitude
c'est dire des choses que les gens
comprennent s'engager sur des
propositions les mettre en oeuvre et
obtenir des résultats
je veux être un président qui obtient
des résultats merci nicolas fargues
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions
c'est jean-michel